Resuelve usando el método de eliminación.
La suma de dos números es 70
y su diferencia es 24,
¿cuáles son esos números?
La suma de dos números es 70,
¿esto cómo se expresa en matemáticas?
Bueno, pues voy a agarrar dos números,
"x" y "y" los voy a sumar
y la suma de estos dos
me tiene que dar 70.
Así de fácil obtengo mi primera ecuación,
ahora dice que su diferencia es 24,
así que "x" menos "y" esto tiene que ser 24 y ojo,
aquí estoy asumiendo que "x"
es el número más grande,
"x" es el número más grande de estos dos.
¡Muy bien!
Y después dice que resolvamos este sistema
de ecuaciones por el método de eliminación,
por lo tanto lo que voy a hacer
es sumar estas dos ecuaciones
para que se cancele una
de estas dos variables.
Ahora, lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que puedo aplicar este método porque estoy sumando 24 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado derecho estoy sumando 24
y del lado izquierdo también
porque yo sé que "x" menos
"y" es exactamente igual a 24,
esto es lo que me dice la otra ecuación.
Así que vamos a hacerlo.
más "y" menos "y" se cancelan,
"x" más "x" es "2x",
"2x" es lo mismo que 70 más 24,
70 más 24 es lo mismo que 94,
por lo tanto obtengo
la ecuación "2x" igual a 94
y fíjate que importante es esto
porque lo que estoy encontrando
es una ecuación con solamente
una incógnita, ¿y cómo lo hice?
eliminando la "y"
sumando estas dos ecuaciones,
recuerda que lo que estoy haciendo realmente
es sumando 24 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado derecho es obvio
que estoy sumando 24 y tal vez me digas,
"oye, pero del lado izquierdo no estoy sumando 24, estoy sumando "x" menos "y""
sin embargo, la segunda ecuación
lo que me dice es exactamente eso,
que "x" menos "y" es igual a 24,
por lo tanto estoy sumando 24
de ambos lados de la ecuación,
solamente que
con nombres distintos y genial,
porque al sumar estas dos ecuaciones
obtengo que "2x" es igual a 94
ó si divido entre 2 ambos lados de la ecuación  voy a obtener que "x" es igual a 94 entre 2, lo cual es 47.
Ya tengo el valor para "x", "x" vale 47, ahora
voy a sustituir este valor en la primera ecuación,
para obtener el valor de "y",
es decir que 47 más "y" es igual a 70
y si yo quito 47 de ambos lados
de la ecuación estos dos se van a ir
y voy a obtener que "y" es igual a 70 menos 47,
lo cual es...
70 menos 47 es 23.
Perfecto, ya tengo la solución de este sistema
de ecuaciones, "x" igual a 47,
"y" igual a 23 cumplen las dos ecuaciones
porque su suma es 70 y por otra parte,
47 menos 23 es lo mismo que 24,
por lo tanto se cumplen ambas ecuaciones.